اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير واهلا بكم
من العربيه
تبلغ قيمتها اكثر من مليارين دولار من
المتوقع ان تضم صواريخ بعيده المدى للمره
الاولى
لشراء صواريخ
150 كيلو مترا ستساعده اوكرانيا
ضرب اهداف الروسيه كانت بعيده المنال
وستخصصوا الاموال ايضا للدفاعات الجويه
ومضادات المسيرات والمدفعيه ورادارات
المراقبه الجويه ومعدلات الاتصالات
بالاضافه الى تجهيز ثلاثه مستشفيات
ميداليه
فالمقابل لم يعلق البيت الابيض على
امكانيه استخدام رئيس بايرن اكثر من اربع
بيئه مليون دولار من اموال الطوارئ تخصصوا
لمركبات مضاد
[موسيقى]
انا وعادل جدل الى الساحه الغربيه هذه
المره ليس على ارسال الدبابات بل المقاتله
وقد تصعد الخلاف الان حول تسليحه اوكرانيا
من عدمه بطائرات المقاتله غربيه الصنع
طلبات تركيب اكثر من مره لكن الاستجابه
لهذا الطلب صعبه وحساسه وسط مخوف من
التورط الغربي بشكل اعمق في الحرب فرنسا
كانت على راسي قائمه الدول التي وافقت
مبدايا على ارسال مقاتلات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا
بريطانيا كانت اكثر حضرا على لسان رئيس
وزراء هيرتش سوناك الذي قال ان ارسال
الطائرات المقاتله لاوكرانيا امر غير عملي
في هذه اللحظه
كانت اكثر تشددا وحسن حيل الامر حيث بدد
الرئيس الامريكي
في الحصول على اف 16 وكذا انه لن يوافق
على ارسال الطائرات المقاتله الى اوكرانيا
مع ضمان احترام المبادئ الثلاثه اولا يجب
ان تؤدي مساعدتنا الى تصعيد للنزاع ثانيا
يجب ان تكون مفيده وفعاله بسرعه واخيرا
يجب ان لا تضعف قدراتنا الدفاعيه
ارسال المقاتلات لم يوقف استمرار تدفق
الدعم العسكري الغربي خصوصا التعاقدات
الامريكيه الاوروبيه الاخيره بارسال
الدبابات حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع النرويجي
ان بلاده ستنقل دبابات ليوبارد اثنان
الالمانيه لاوكرانيا نهايه باريس القادم
فيما لم يحدد الوزير عددها
بلاده تملك 36 دبابه من طراز اثنان وكانت
المانيا انها ستسمح للدول الاخرى التي
تمتلك هذه الدبابات الالمانيه الصنع
بنقلها الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير
طلب وزير الخارجيه ليتوانيا دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي باطاردي سفراء روسيا في وقت انت
تصعد التوتراتد دبلوماسيه بين دول البلطيق
وموسكو منذ الهجوم الروسي ضد اوكرانيا
في عاصمه اوروبيه
الروسيه لا تمثل المؤسسه الدبلوماسيه بل
الدعائيه
اعلنت وزاره التجاره الامريكيه فرض قيود
تجاريه جديده على سبع كيارات ايرانيه بسبب
انتاجها طائرات المسيره استخدمتها روسيا
في مهاجمه اوكرانيا
شركات والمنظمات الرياضيه وضعت على قائمه
الرقابه على صادرات الامريكيه وتتضمه تلك
القائمه منخرطه في انشطه تهدد الامن
القومي وسياسه الخارجيه الامريكيه
الكائنات الايرانيه تضم شركه لتصنيع
محركات الطائرات والقوه الجويه التابعه
للحرس الثوري الايراني
وشركه القدس لصناعه الطيران وشاهد لصناعات
الطيران ايضا بمقاله ايران العقوبات لا
تؤثر على قدره طيران في انتاج الطائرات
المسيره التي تصنع محليا بشكل كامل على حد
قوله
ايضا اعلنت الخارجيه الاستراليه فرض
عقوبات على 16 مسؤولا ايرانيا بعضهم من
الحرس الثوري
وكيان واحد لتورطهم في قمع الاحتجاجات في
ايران
والخرجه الاستراليه قالت ان الحكومه فرضت
ايضا عقوبات اضافيه على اربعه افراد وبعد
كيانات ايران لمشاركتهم في انتاج وتوريد
الطائرات المسيره الى روسيا واستخدامها في
الحرب ضد اوكرانيا
في شان الايرانيه اخر هدد مستشار وفريق
التفاوض النووي الايراني محمد مرندي
اوكرانيا بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
واسلحه ايرانيه مختلفه
ذكر تورطه اوكرانيا في هجوم بطائرات
البصيره اسرائيليه على مدينه اصفهان
مثل تلك الحماقات على حد وصفه
ايضا وصف الرئيس الايراني
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها ايران منذ مقتل
الشاب ميني وصفها بالاضطرابات وقال انها
تسببت في اضرار اقتصاده
المظاهرات عباره عن شغب تسبب في ندره
الدولار
والدوله اعمال الشغب والعقوبات وجهان
لعمله واحده الاحتجاجات تسببت في اضرار
الاقتصاديه الدولار
هكذا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيهن خلال مؤتمر
صحفي في القدس الغربيه انا الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل ملتزمتان بمنع ايران من
الحصول على سلاحين
والولايات المتحده لديهم التزام مشترك بان
لا تمتلك ايران سلاح نوويه ومواصله الوقوف
جنبا الى الجنب مع بلدان اخرى ضد الكثير
من الانشطه الايرانيه
التكنولوجيا الطائرات المسيره لروسيا
لاستخدامها في عمليتها العسكريه باوكرانيا
قالت رساله الجمهوريه سانتيا لوميز ان نهج
اداره ترامب تجاه ايران كان افضل لبلادها
ولا اسرائيل على حد سواء مشيره الى انه في
حال اطيحت الفرصه امام ايران لضربه
اسرائيل ستكون الولايات المتحده هدفها
التاريخ
ايران لذلك يمكننا حمايته اقرب حليفا لنا
في الشرق الاوسط وكذلك حمايه امريكا لانه
بمجرد ان تتاح الايران الفرصه لالحاق
الادب اسرائيل ستكون امريكا هدفها التالي
هذا هو قلقي
ايضا في هذه النشره ولكن بعد الفاصل
رئيس الوزراء العراقيه تعاهدوا بفرض
اجراءات حقيقيه للكشف عن الاموال المهربه
للخرج
اهلا بكم من جديد
الحرس الوطني
من الحقائق في جمله من الحقائق التي تتعلق
بجمله من الجرائم التي تم ارتكبها
ولابد من محاسبتي من اقترفه
الشعب
يريد المحاسبه
عليكم
وعلى الكرات الشرفاء
ان يقوم بدورهم
كاملا
حتى يتم التصدي
لمن تامر على الدوله
بسنوات الماضيه
يتامرون على الدوله
وقال الرئيس سعيد ان هناك جمله من الجرائم
تم ارتكبها ولابد من محاسبه من اقترفها
مشددا على ان الشعب يريد تلك المحاسبه من
دبر العمليه
هو الذي اغرق هؤلاء
وتمت الابحاث ولكن لابد من محاكمتي هؤلاء
لانهم اغتالوا
هؤلاء الذين
اغرقوهم في هذا المركب وكانت العمليه
مدبره
على رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد
ستتوصل الى صيغه النهائيه لتنظيم تواجد
قوات التحالف الدولي في العراق
الحقيقيه
من بغداد الى الاقليم ومنه الى دول الجوار
سوداني يوضح ان عمليه تغيير المناصب
الامنيه الحساسه بعيده عن اي تدخل سياسي
وغير خاطئه للمحاصه الحزبيه
في طرابلس تسعه وزاره الداخليه بحكومه
لوحده الليبيه في ارض سيطرتها وجودها في
العاصمه كخطبه الاولى قبل الانتقال الى
مديريه طوق طرابلس ومن ثم الى باقي المدن
في ظل انتشار السلاح والسيطره بعض تشكيلات
على الاحياء
خطط امنيه لبست الامن في طرابلس اعلنتها
وزاره الداخليه بحكومه الوحده الوطنيه من
خلال نشر تمركزات تنميه للاجهزه النظاميه
التابعه للدوله على مدار الساعه في كل
شوارع العاصمه بعد دعم مراكز الشرطه
ومكونات الوزاره بالمعدات والاسلحه التي
تجعلهم قادرين على مواجهه اي خروقات امنيه
في ظل انتشار السلاح في البلاد
ليه الشارع العام
للسيارات
يعني نظره معالي الوزير
كافيه لاعطاء نتائج سريعه خصوصا مع وجود
ما يقارب 20 مليون قطعه سلاح في البلاد
بحسب تقديرات اعلاميه انا اعتقد انه
معالجه الملف الامنيات الامنيه التي تحدث
بين حين والاخر في العاصمه ترى بس اكبر
بكثير ما انتم تعالجه خطه امنيه تطلقها
وزاره الداخليه الكثير يعني يصف انه الفرق
او الخروقات الامنيه اسبابها سياسيه
المواطنون يرحبون بمثل هذه العمليات كونها
تدعم التوجه الى فرض القانوني والتقليل من
سطوه التشكيلات المسلحه
الانتشار الامني توا الفتره هذه شو في 18
ايام تحسن الله الله يبارك
واقعه وان شاء الله الافضل للافضل فيه
الناس عادي
بواب عاديه
سياره مجهوله الهويه من بينها مركبات
تابعه لمجموعه مسلحه خطط امنيه جديده
تحاول الداخليه تنفيذها لضبط الامن داخل
وفرض هيبه الدوله وكبح جماح التشكيلات
المسلحه فيما يعمل سكان العاصمه ان تنجح
هذه الخطوات في خفض معدلات الجريمه وضبط
الامن داخل المدينه منير الاشهب طرابلس
العربيه
فرنسي
احتجاجها على رفع سن التقاعد وفقا
النقابات العماليه شهدت تظاهرات مواجهات
المحدوده بين المتظاهرين وشوطه فيما توعدت
المعارضه اليساريه الحكومه بتحركات جديده
تخلو من المسافرين لان قطاع النقل هو ابرز
القطاعات التي تشارك في هذا الاضراب
بالاضافه الى قطاعات التعليم والسكك
الحديديه والطاقه معطل انتاج الكهربائي
واوقف عمليه نقل الوقود من المصافي الى
المحطات لكن مشهد خلو وسائل النقل من
المسافرين والمؤسسات من الموظفين كان
مختلفا جدا في الخارج
بها الفرنسي الى الشارع للاحتجاج على رفع
سن التقاعد وايضا ارتفاع الاسعار وترد
الاوضاع الميشيه هي موجه ثانيه من اصل
ثلاث موجات للاضراب والتظاهر دعت اليها 8
نقابات والاحزاب اليساريه مجتمعه ما يضع
الرئيس الفرنسي امام تحد جديد مع الشارع
يقول الرجل الاول في الحزب الاشتراكي انهم
سيكملونه حتى النهايه
لن تتوقف ستستمر هذه الحركه حتى تتراجع
الحكومه وتسحب هذا المشروع تظاهرات الموجه
الثانيه شهدت زياده في زخم المشاركه وقالت
النقابات ان نصف مليون نزلوا الى شوارع
العاصمه بينما قدرت الشرطه اعدادهم بنحو
سبعه وثمان الفن الاستخبارات الفرنسيه
توقعت مشاركه جماعات يساريه عنيفه صدقه
التوقعات ووقعت صدامات محدوده لكن سرعان
ما عدا الهدوء واستانف المتظاهرون تحركهم
اخرى لتحرك لان الحكومه لا تنصت الى
الحركه الاجتماعيه في الشارع لكن رغم كل
هذا الغضب لا تبدي الحكومه اهتماما
بالعدول عن هذا القانون وتقول انها منفتحه
على النقاش بعض البنود لكن رفع سن التقاعد
الى 64 عاما ستظل مساله غير قابله للنقاش
فاتن دهوك العربيه
باريس
[موسيقى]
الجمهوري رونالدو
وفي نيورك طالب البدع العربي عقوبات على
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
ونجلاء الاكبر مؤسسه ترامب ومحامي بسبب
ردودهم على قضيه مدنيه بقيمه 250 مليون
دولار دعوه احتياط ضدهم او ضده
الدعوه بعد تحقيق شامل دام ثلاث سنوات
هذا ويواجه كل من الرئيس الامريكي الحالي
جو بايدن والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
تحقيقات بسبب احتفاضهما بوثائق سريه في
مكاتبهما او منازلهما الخاصه فما القصه
وثائق سريه لا لا ليست سريه ان كانت سريه
او غير ذلك كيف يمكن ان ينتهي الامر بتلك
الوثائق الحساسه في غير محلها وكيف يتم
التخلص منها عند كل صباح يتم اعداد ملخص
يومي استخباراتي لشاغل المكتب البيضاوي
المواد الاكثر سريه وحساسيه عاده ما يتم
اعدادها خارج البيت الابيض داخل الوكالات
الاستخباراتيه المتخصصه
باستخدام طابعات خاصه متصله بنظام البريد
الالكتروني المصنف
يقوم الافراد العاملون هناك بطباعه
المستندات وتجميعها في ملف خاص
بمجرد ان يصبح الملف جاهزا يستلمه الشخص
الموكل اليه ايصاله الى البيت الابيض ثم
يتم وضع الملف في حقيبه مغلقه جيدا فيما
يسجل المسؤولون في المكتب بيانات تلك
الوثيقه المستلمه من استلمها وفي اي وقت
غادر والجهه المرسله اليها الوثيقه بعد
الانتهاء من تلك العمليه واصال الحقيبه من
المفترض ان تتم اعاده تلك الوثيقه الى
مكانها مره اخرى
حيث سيتم تسجيل عودتها وفي معظم الحالات
تحرق تلك المستندات او تتم تلك العمليه
لاحقا
ومع ذلك في بعض الحالات يختار الشخص
المسؤول الاحتفاظ بالوثائق لايام او حتى
اسابيع
عمليه معقده يتم بها نقل الوثائق السريه
وارجاعها ومن ثم التخلص منها الا ان
وثائقي فلتت من قبضه تلك العمليه الامر
الذي اوقع الرئيسيين بيض وترامب في فخها
فخ الوثائق السريه
[موسيقى]
عقوبات الامريكيه واستراليه تطالب افرادا
وكيانات ايرانيه على صله بتوريد السيارات
والصواريخ لروسيا
الى صديق
على الدوله
[موسيقى]